the new commissioner of the metropolitan
police has just been appointed that's
terry not let's bring in our crime
correspondent martin brunt uh martin
tell us who he is because he's got a big
job to do hasn't he's taking over a
police force has just been put into
special measures
he's got an immense job ahead of him and
the man who has vowed has vowed to do it
and to restore the mets reputation is
sir mark rowley
uh who retired from the met in
2018 he was at the time one of the most
senior officers
at the metropolitan police and the last
job he held there
was as head of counter-terror not just
for the met but
a role he
held on a national basis and he led the
response to the wave of attacks
in london in 2017
he did apply for the job uh originally
when it was last vacant but lost out to
cressida dick
he had applied also i understand for the
job of running the national crime agency
uh but lost out uh to somebody else on
that job so for the last four years sir
mark rowley has worked in the private
sector but he has been a regular uh
pundit particularly
on counter-terror matters um
so announced in the last few minutes by
the home secretary that
he's the uh the chosen uh candidate uh
he was one of two
uh who were left in the race and was
clearly
uh the front ru runner his um his rival
was
nick
f grave who is a a serving still serving
assistant commissioner at the met but
presumably
he was seen to have been too
close to cressida dick was one of her
lieutenants through the last two or
three years of very troubled times at
the met so at least sir mark rowley has
not been associated with more recent
problems at the metropolitan police now
the home office has said that he will
need to focus
on getting the basics right restoring
confidence in policing delivering a
breaking crime a beating crime plan
rather
and making the capital streets safer
um pretty obvious uh targets for him um
sir mark has said in a statement that
he's honored
to get the job
he said our mission is to lead the
renewal of policing by consent which has
been so heavily dented in recent years
as trust and confidence have fallen uh
he went on to say we will deliver more
trust less crime
and high standards so he's set himself
pretty high targets
but i don't think that he will be in any
way underestimating the task of ahead of
him with a force in special measures um
the metropolitan police one of six
uh uk police forces uh undergoing
uh real close scrutiny by the police
watchdog so he'll probably give himself
i don't know a year 18 months to turn
the force around he's got to do it
quickly after two or three years of
momentous scandals he really does have
to restore public confidence in the met
but also i think to restore confidence
in his staff